the idea for both of you is that the
market offers the solution for
alleviating poverty is that a fair
statement I don't know if I would say
that it offers the solution I would say
that it offers a particular solution
which not speaking for Julia but
certainly for myself is perhaps a more
disciplined one in that it brings
commercial rigor to businesses that are
growing in and serving lower-income
groups do you agree with that I do agree
i would just add that there are certain
social challenges that cannot be
necessarily tackled through businesses
social justice is difficult to find
their business model but there are
others where if you find a sustainable
financially sustainable business model
you can scale and increase the impact
tremendously because you're not going to
be dependent on limited amount of
charitable dollars but you can engage
capital and people who require
commercial return to tackle those very
cute social problems and that's the
beauty and excitement about the impact
investing